the definition of security what is the
definition of security all right a
security in the form of an investment
contract that's what's happening here
four things have to happen one has to be
an investment two into a common
enterprise three you were led to believe
hang on investment common enterprise
common enterprise you have to believe a
reasonable expectation of profit okay
and four and you rely on the efforts of
others for that profit if you meet those
four factors and you must meet all four
then it is an investment contract a
fourth one so investment common
enterprise
reasonable expectation of profit and
you're relying on others relying on
others
to help make profit to make the profit
so let me ask you a question yep
this if this is
what the definition of security is i've
been serious seven since
day before 9 11 whatever uh 2001 i've
been serious seven 66 31 26 all those
licenses
tilted to have my licenses right your
seven can drink now
my series seven can drink now you're
right
in one year in one year in a year you
can train not yet they would have to
drink at a party like we typically would
do but
if that's what you're saying how many
people and and this is a
very simple question how many people buy
xrp ethereum or bitcoin for its
technology rather than as a source of
investment that is a great great
question because there are let me
address this there are a group of people
i represent that
use the technology they go on the ledger
the xrp ledger and they use it as a
bridge asset they buy casino coin
there's a decentralized exchange part of
the uh ledger and they uh trade assets
to trade different currencies yeah it's
like a pseudo-dark web now man and so
there are users of the the technology
yeah um
and um
but there's no doubt that there's a lot
of people are speculating right whether
it's bitcoin ethereum i've read it as
much as like 97
that's what i'm saying so so that's the
part where
for them
they don't like that right i mean you
just defined if i ask right now and
listen most people are probably not
going to say exactly but if i ask right
now why are you buying bitcoin oh it's a
great investment no no no no don't use
that word right you know don't use that
word you know like in in
in as a financial advisor the the what's
the one word you cannot use as an
advisor you know like the the one word
you have to be careful selling mutual
funds or stocks or bonds what's the word
the g word what's the g word guaranteed
you can't say i do i guarantee you the
stock market with american funds the
last since 1934 when american funds
investment company of act america came
out it's done 12.2 percent dude you can
i guarantee you you can't say that right
so that's the g word so the investment
word you cannot use that with these
technologies okay number one
you're looking at it as an investment
common enterprise reasonable expectation
of profit most people have a reasonable
expectation of profiting
and then relying on somebody else to
make the profit one can say that about
all of them right so then the
conversation becomes decentralized or
centralized
many will say well uh uh you know
bitcoin and ethereum are the most
decentralized uh product out there right
let's just say that's what many will say
right but then they'll say
look uh
ripple is somewhat centralized and
they'll come back and say no it's not
it's pretty decentralized only seven
percent is centralized right
how much uh how much does it matter
whether
the technology or the coin or the wallet
is centralized or decentralized how much
does that matter great question and let
me just point on your your point about
the investment i'm sure that ripple
lawyers and others they don't want me
talking about
investments and things like that so
you're 100 right now i will tell you
that you have to focus on the token
versus the technology yes the network
versus the token ripple i will tell you
right now i i can absolutely win any
argument that the xrp ledger is more
decentralized than the ethereum network
i put every dollar i got it
first of all because
if ripple
went away they filed bankruptcy tomorrow
right
xrp ledger continues xrp continues
vitalik buterin dies
you're going to tell me ethereum's going
to continue to go mark cuban just
recently said when he was challenged by
bitcoinmax he's on a on a clubhouse i
was listening in and they were like
saying to mark they were like look it's
not even ether 2.0 they're going from
proof of work to proof of stake
you know they keep promising promising
promising to never deliver and mark says
i think that vitalik's vitalik's gonna
figure it out and i'm putting my money
on that that's centralization right
right there now the problem for ripple
interesting is that they own 50
of the xrp
okay that's token centralization that's
token centralization and that's the real
problem for them and a lot of people
look at that and say well you own half
of the token that's the market
manipulation people were talking about
they're worried about that and that's
why brad garden house came up with the
escrow where they put it all in escrow
and each month only a billion of the 50
billion will come out and then they'll
go back in escrow and they can't touch
that's good he did that by the way very
very good he did that very smart you
made a great point too about about
vitalik like i'm a big ethereum guy
anybody that's been listening to podcast
knows i'm very very very bullish on
ethereum but i'm bullish on ethereum
because of italic same way that i i own
tesla because of elon musk elon musk
bails on tesla i'm out right you know so
the
the you know proponent of the great man
theory that's a great great point that
you're making so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you